[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday july 5th i'm julie chang for the
wall street journal filling in for zoe
thomas
a few weeks ago we talked about a google
engineer who said he believed one of the
company's artificial intelligence chat
bots had become sentient the news
prompted no small measure of public
reaction
what is going on here i mean how on
earth can they have conversations i mean
lambda passed the touring test well i
hate to say it annette but this really
is not sentient artificial intelligence
this is a future message for skynet i
never insulted robots okay
jokes aside the incident does raise the
question how close are we really to
machines achieving consciousness ai
technology does permeate our daily lives
and companies have been investing in
this area to keep pushing its boundaries
after all but what is it actually
capable of our reporter karen howe has
been speaking with industry leaders and
experts about this and she joins me now
hi karen thanks for coming on the show
hi julie thanks so much for having me
what are some of the more ambitious
goals that companies have with
artificial intelligence where do they
want this tech to go
yeah it's um it's interesting in i think
the industry there's sort of a split
that's happened where some of the larger
companies are much more focused on just
very practical use cases like a really
unsexy
back office logistics type ai but then
there's this sort of sci-fi element to
ai development as well
where ai as a scientific field was
actually originally founded on this sort
of
wild premise to try and recreate all of
human intelligence or create a super
intelligence something that will
ultimately be able to do everything
better than humans and the term that
people use for this kind of really
ambitious sci-fi like ai is artificial
general intelligence and a lot of
companies have been pouring money into
this tech google for instance has been
betting big on language generation
systems ironically it was two of its own
engineers that came out and warned about
the dangers of ai
margaret mitchell and tim nick gebru
they were co-leads on the ethical ai
team at google what have these
dissenters been saying what mitchell and
gabriel
warned was
as we continue to see these systems
perform these like seemingly really
human-like things generate essays start
talking in this very human-like way in
the form of a chatbot
people are going to start trusting these
systems far more than they actually
deserve to be trusted because in ai
research there's sort of an
understanding that
no matter how much these systems have
been able to mimic human-like
speech
that doesn't actually mean that they
understand what they're saying it
doesn't mean that they understand what
humans are saying these systems are just
good at making associations between
words
which is ultimately what helps you
extract the right results from the web
in response to a search query
but
for the average public user they're not
going to really understand that gap and
so
they were kind of warning at the time
the more that we have this gap the more
it actually becomes dangerous because
people are going to start using these
systems in places that they're not
supposed to use them they're going to
start trusting them more than they want
so an example that they gave
in a paper they wrote at the time about
this
was facebook's ai system
in
2017 mistranslated
good morning in arabic to hurt them in
english and attack them in hebrew and it
actually led to the arrest of a
palestinian man by israeli police
because they just believed the
translation and didn't actually check
with
an arabic speaking colleague what it
actually said and it took them
a while to actually realize the error
facebook said in response that they're
getting better and better every day and
that these ai systems have improved
since then
yeah and this idea of perception versus
reality with ai and the issue that
gabriel and mitchell brought up it oddly
clashed with an incident surrounding
another engineer at google blake lemoine
lemoine was essentially chatting with an
experimental chat box called lambda and
became convinced that lambda had become
sentient he even believed it deserved
legal representation
the important caveat to this
is that lemoine specifically says that
he
is a mystic incorporating aspects of
christianity and
spiritual practices such as meditation
so when he talks about lambda being
sentient he's specifically talking in a
religious capacity as a mystic priest
not in his capacity as a scientist
and so he
hired a lawyer for lambda to talk to
lambda about lambda giving consent
to be
part of these experiments to be used in
this way
since then google has come out and
really been adamant that lambda is not
sentient
and it's important to note that in
mainstream consensus scientific
consensus it's also considered an
incredibly fringe opinion that ai
systems
could become sentient because ultimately
they're just data processing machines
so google came out and said this
machine's not sentient the scientific
community has come out and also said no
machines are not sentient but blake
lemoyne's story spread like wildfire
what were the real life implications of
this and the gap that exists between
perception versus reality when it comes
to ai yeah so researchers
definitely were alarmed by how much this
narrative took hold because it once
again reveals this really really big gap
between perception and reality and it's
not just dangerous because of some of
the examples that were raised like
facebook's mistranslation it's also
dangerous because ultimately
policymakers are part of the public
they're part of the people that become
beholden to this perception gap and so
increasingly
more and more of the regulations or
proposed regulations that are addressing
ai harms are starting to
specifically just target harms that come
from ai systems from being hyper
competent so things like discrimination
manipulation this inherently assumes
that these ai systems are really good at
what they do but what they've sort of
left out of the conversation is harms
that come from ai systems just not
working
all right that was our reporter karen
howe karen thank you again for being
here thank you so much for having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm julie chang for the wall street
journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
you